Of all the Android launch devices,
the Nexus 1 will always
hold a special place in my heart.
That's not to take anything away
from my first Android device,
the HTC G1, that launched Android
to the world with its distinctive chin
and slide-out keyboard.
Or the HTC Magic,
first prerelease android phone
I got to dog food
when I joined Google.
And the first, the wave of devices
we gave every attendee
starting at Google I/O in 2009.
2010 was the year Android went from
"that's interesting" to global phenomenon.
Growing from 100,000
activations a day in May,
to over 300,000 by December.
That was seriously helped
by the release of the Motorola Droid.
I can still remember
the offices here in Building 44,
echoing with the constant refrain
of "Droid" as each device rebooted.
The Droid was the first of the thinner,
higher res, more powerful Android devices
that have since become standard.
And it was also the device whose
release on Verizon here in the U.S.,
really kicked off the flood
of Android activations.
But I was a Londoner then,
and the Droid was
a [inaudible] only phone,
so it was never really
a device I truly used.
Then, there was the Nexus 1,
code-named Passion.
The first device I felt was pure Android,
was also the phone we brought with us
on our 2010 Android
Developer Labs World Tour.
Me and my colleagues
traveled across the world.
Seven cities in ten days,
introducing over 20,000 developers
to Android by way of presentations
and a free Nexus 1.
As a result, I made
a lot of friends across Europe,
and learned exactly
how many boxes of phones
I can carry across snow drifts
in Stockholm, and icy roads in Berlin.
Since then, The Nexus S4 and 5
have each improved on what it takes
to make a great Android phone.
And OEMs across the world, have created
thousands of different Android devices.
Starting with the Motorola Xoom,
which led Android's
official expansion into tablet's,
and leading the way
for the Nexus 7 and 10.
But that was just the start.
Those changes paved the way
for the Android [inaudible]
to grow into what could be,
the brains behind anything
from phones and tablet's, to TVs,
cars and wearables, like Android Wear.
It's impossible to know, what comes next.
Who knows?
Maybe the next Android devices,
will be Androids themselves.